A gruesome scene that caught everyone
off guard. A darker Riddler than we've
ever seen. What scene went too far? Keep
watching. Spoilers for "The Batman" ahead!
A new Batman movie has burst forth from the night,
and audiences have been loving the new iteration
of the iconic character. Robert Pattinson
perfectly fits the mold of both Bruce Wayne
and the Caped Crusader. And of course, no Batman
is complete without a sinister villain to fight.
Batman goes up against the likes of Penguin
and Carmine Falcone in the film, but the main
baddie that overshadows them all is Riddler.
Batman is known just as much for his intellect
as his brawn, making the Riddler a perfect
match for him. He leaves behind riddles at
every crime scene, and while they may
puzzle everyone else, Batman is able to
get a good handle on the situation ... for
the most part. This version of the Riddler
is unlike anything that's come before, taking
on the persona of a Zodiac-like serial killer.
Riddler may have killed before in the comics, but
unless you count most of Jim Carrey's portrayal,
he's never done anything quite this atrocious.
"Does anybody else feel like a fried egg?"
There are many gruesome scenes in "The Batman"
that resemble moments you might expect out of
something like "Se7en" or "Prisoners." But there's
one scene involving Riddler that may be tough to
watch even for the bravest souls in the audience.
It's obvious right from the get-go that Riddler
doesn't have any sympathy for his victims.
In his mind, they are the corrupt elite,
and they deserve what they have coming to them.
He's not even above sending a video of one of his
victims' demises to the local news so that
everyone can see his grand plan in action.
During "The Batman," we see a video
made by Riddler himself depicting
his capture of Commissioner Pete Savage. The
commissioner isn't as clean as everyone thought,
and Riddler highlights this fact by strapping
an apparatus to his body. This device contains
various tubes linked to a rat cage, allowing
the rodents to burrow into him. While we don't
see anything too graphic, just the thought of
dying that way is a painful visual to imagine.
It's something that a lot of audiences
thought went too far, and if you find
yourself having a tingle of familiarity
while watching the scene, you aren't alone.
The moment bears striking similarities to a scene
in 2008's "The Dark Knight" when the Joker sends a
tape to the news depicting his torture of a Batman
impersonator. That was also a horrifying scene,
particularly since it showed a darker side
to Joker than what most people had seen in
a film up to that point.
"Look at me. Look at me."
From Riddler's tape to the rest of his
time in "The Batman," it will be hard
to look at the character the same way again.
Villains sending ominous videos to the local
news isn't the only thing "The Batman" and "The
Dark Knight" have in common. They both offer more
grounded takes on the character, introducing us
to villains who could theoretically exist in the
real world. They both depict Batman wanting to go
after the mob and organized crime plaguing Gotham.
And that's just the tip of the iceberg.
Both Batman movies also make excellent
use of their funeral scenes. In "The Dark
Knight," there's a massive outdoor funeral
procession for Police Commissioner Loeb. People
are naturally on edge from the Joker's attacks,
and as everyone should have suspected, Joker
targets the funeral and makes an attempt on the
mayor's life while he's at the podium. Similarly,
"The Batman" has a funeral scene for the fallen
mayor. The festivities are held inside this
time around, but that doesn't stop Riddler
from sending a runaway car into the building
to scare the daylights out of everyone inside.
And of course, there's a special surprise
waiting for everyone inside the vehicle.
"Let's clear this place out now."
Of course, these examples don't suggest that
the two movies are anything alike. They both stand
alone as incredible pieces of superhero cinema,
raising the bar for any future projects. Anything
they have in common is purely surface level,
but there's honestly no way to avoid comparisons
between two of the best Batman movies to date.
Both movies are brutal, and as this
particular Riddler scene proves,
they contain some genuinely terrifying scenes
that bring the Batman into darker territory.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Batman
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.